And welcome back.
So we now have
leaderboards in our game.
And we have this lovely view all
of my leaderboards controller.
However, it would
be awfully nice
if while I were in the
middle of playing a game,
or done with a game,
I could still also see
the high scores
that were available
in that particular level.
You know, just so I know what
score I have to beat, or so on.
And so, we can do that with
our leaderboard controller.
Unlike the leaderboards
controller, with an s,
the leaderboard controller
lets you immediately bring up
the scores for a
specific leaderboard.
So this is pretty easy to do.
Let's jump into my
game view controller,
and let's look at our
little nib file here.
And I'm going to add a button.
Let's put it down
here at the bottom,
and we'll call it leaderboards.
I guess leaderboard, with
an exclamation point,
because we're super excited
about this leaderboard.
And we'll anchor it
to the bottom here.
Boop.
Done.
And I'm going to bring up
my helper view control--
or, my helper editor.
Let's go into automatic, and
in our game view controller.
Maybe here we will add, a view
leaderboard button was pressed.
Action.
There you go.
So let's go into our game
view controller here,
and we'll edit this thing.
So, first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to create
a leaderboard controller.
Leaderboard VC equals
GBG leaderboard
controller alloc init
with leaderboard ID.
And I don't actually know
what our leaderboard ID is,
because we've gone ahead
and abstracted it away
in my leaderboard manager class.
So maybe what I'll do
is-- let me go ahead
and create a little
class method here,
that will return
an NSString, which
will be leaderboard ID
for difficulty level.
And we'll pass in
our difficulty level.
Simple enough, and
I think actually
implementing this is also
pretty straightforward.
Basically go into
return, and maybe we'll
just cast this, just to make
sure, leaderboard IDs level.
And you know, it wouldn't
kill me to add some
[? arrange bounds ?]
[? checking ?] here,
but I'm not going to,
because this is a sample app.
So let's go back to our
game view controller,
and let's create a little
NSString leaderboard
ID equals-- and maybe go up here
and import our GMN leaderboard
manager.
Now let's go back
down here, and now we
can create our NSString,
that's our leaderboard ID.
And that will equal GMN
leaderboard manager,
leaderboard ID for difficulty
level self dot game Diff.
And now, we can basically
say our leaderboard VC
is our leaderboard controller
alloc init with leaderboard ID,
leaderboard ID.
Leaderboard VC, leaderboard
delegate will be self.
And then we can [? call ?]
self, present, view controller,
our leaderboard VC, animated
yes, completion handler no.
We're going to get a little
warning, because we haven't
declared ourself as a
GPG leaderboard delegate,
so let's do that.
I'll go up here, and
we'll do it right here.
Remember, this is leaderboard
controller delegate, not
leaderboards
controller delegate.
And now we can add
our delegate method.
Leaderboard view
controller did finish,
self dismiss, the view
controller animated yes,
completion no.
And we're done.
So now I can run this, and maybe
I can jump into my easy game
here.
And I'm thinking maybe before
I start playing this game,
let's see what the
leaderboard says.
And they can look
and say, oh look,
this guy Todd here, he's got
an all-time score of three,
no way I can beat that.
So maybe I'll go back, and
check out my medium game, here,
if I view the leaderboard.
Remember, we're creating
a leaderboard controller
with a leaderboard ID of
our medium leaderboard,
so we'll directly
bring up the scores
for this medium
leaderboard, that's great.
And then I say, well, I
guess let's just check out
the hard game.
And here, in my leaderboard
I've got no scores yet.
And so maybe I as
a player now say,
well, this is clearly
the game I want to play,
because I'll get the top
high score, or whatever.
So there you go.
We now have learned
how to submit
a score to a leaderboard,
we've learned
how to bring up the
leaderboards controller, which
displays all leaderboards
within a game.
And we've now seen how to bring
up individual leaderboards,
which would be very useful if,
at the end of the level, say,
you wanted to show players
what the top scores were
for that level.
So there you go,
that's about everything
you need to start adding some
leaderboards into your game.
No MySQL database required.
Really no database
required on your part,
we do all that database work.
So, go ahead and start
adding these to your games,
and remember, the best part
is all this stuff works
on both iOS and Android.
So if I had my cross platform
version of Guess My Number,
people could be competing
against all their friends,
no matter what kind
of phone they owned,
which is pretty awesome.
So there you go,
in the next lesson,
we're going to start taking
a look at Cloud Save.
This, I think, is one of
the most powerful features
that we provide.
It's just a very simple, pretty
straightforward-to-use Cloud
Save solution that, again,
works cross-platform.
So, your Android players
can save their state,
no matter what the
device they're on.
Your iOS players can
save their state,
no matter what
device they're on.
And even if you were to have
an Android phone and an iOS
tablet, you'd be able to
save your game across both
of those platforms, which
I think is pretty awesome.
So we'll start taking a look
at that in the next lesson.
Stay tuned.